we saw Joffrey die this season did we in
season four at the purple wedding as
it's called by the fans what was your
reaction wasn't everybody's reaction I
wanted it to be even more bloody and
more I wanted to be really awful but it
wasn't very nice but I wanted to be even
worse than that and I think we've all
been dying for that there was a
wonderful thing in the first series
which I'm sure you all remember when she
nearly pushes him over the parapet and
we also wanted that and it hasn't
happened for four series and suddenly
what was it like being on set for the
shooting of that wedding because we have
various scenes with you and at the table
while the piece is going on yeah yeah
actually you asked what it was like it
was absolutely not exciting because
there was so many of us everybody had to
have that crack of the whip you know I
had everyone had to be shot on I was
hanging around it was really waiting
waiting waiting while other people had
their long shots and short shots on this
side and that side and the other side
from above every but they were
determined to get it absolutely right
and by god they did so it was three very
boring days I hate to tell you but that
doesn't mean to say we weren't
enthusiastic about it but when you're on
your own and you're enthusiastic and
there's a lot going on but sometimes
there wasn't a lot going on there was it
just somebody bringing in glass of wine
across or something like that but you
were in the shot so you had to be there
and shut up with your friend or whatever
it was and then someone had to be on one
point had to be on ones toes but that
having been said it was a pretty
tiresome these very big scenes in films
always are I remember speaking with he
was a great friend of mine Charlton
Heston talking about then her but he was
in the middle of that a great chariot
ride of course but he said it was so
boring round
round and round these poor extras I'm to
sit there day after day after day
fainting and things like that because I
had nothing to do except go
and so they can be very boring but
that's the way you make films and that's
been happening since the very beginning
of big films and of course we had your
scene in the trial with Tyrion as well
what was that like shooting that well I
got on very well with him ever everybody
does I why not
he is from my money and I'm sure most
people with money that my favorite
character in the whole thing he could
although you naughty sometime and he
shot my baby badly not just naughtily
his heart is always in the right place
and you always know that he's sussing
out what your sussing out it's a very
clever character because the audience
immediately identifies with him yeah I
know that I know that go on tell him
tell him tell him oh no you haven't told
him
yes you told him brilliant and and he's
got this extraordinary ability in the
character to talk tongues with Tywin and
who's a difficult one to talk with but I
thought one of the best scenes in the
whole series was not someone being
killed or whatever they're all wonderful
but not that long see the scene between
him and Tyrion and Tywin about how he
was born and how tyrant wanted to chuck
him into the water and that hold that
face-to-face thing you know you're a
load of rubbish but you've got to do
your stuff now you've got to [ __ ] that
girl and you've got to make a get an
heir and but it was a very very good
very well-written scene I thought and
they played it wonderful I think this
Charles dawn so I've known for so many
years now since 1975 I think
and he's given some fine work this is a
party which is just absolutely Charles
dance
down to the very essence his core he
plays it absolutely brilliantly he just
knows how to play it and had I been 30
years younger I'd have died to play that
how likely always see you in season five
of Game of Thrones oh very likely if I
know I've got five episodes so far yeah
yeah I start filming I didn't know
August I think
you